to answer the question what is a
traditional woman yeah I am confused I
would say it's like it's a woman that's
pure she's youthful um and if she's not
youthful she's married so like you can
have a traditional woman that's married
if she's older
um she has to like prioritize the family
above all else so I would say like she's
the type of girl that has like Kevin
Samuels would say do you have a cookbook
and it's true like what how do you how
do you Foster tradition in your in your
home
but I I don't think you can be a
traditional woman unless you're either
married or a virgin I feel like being
traditional is boring like as women I
feel like we're constantly being told
how to be all the time like you have to
be like this
this is you're a feminist
are you a feminine yeah I guess so like
okay okay I'm not I'm not on any one
side I'm just lit I think I'm here today
to just learn right so do you now think
because being um what what is boring in
being a traditional
woman like the whole idea of like
staying at home and cooking and like
looking after the kids like
do you think you only think that way
because you're exposed to so much more
you know there's more that you can do
okay yes like that's why I said sorry so
can I ask the woman here do you classify
yourself as a modern or a traditional
woman I think
if I think most everyone does both yeah
like I would love to be a traditional
woman but I don't have that option
because maybe I've made decisions or
I've gone through certain things in life
that now I may be deemed by the likes of
you guys I'm no longer traditional I
feel like you can go through periods as
well like when you're younger you might
be like non-traditional and as you get
older you start to learn okay maybe
there's some value in being a business
decrease in value yeah like the whole
point is like girls want to sleep around
in their 20s and then at 30 run to a man
and like but you've lost the things
you've that men value by the time you're
30 you're no longer pure you're no
longer youthful and so men are kind of
tired of it because what happens is
they'll date the bad boys the rappers
whatever in their 20s and then they hit
30. one guy thinks like this is his
lucky ticket this girl's super into him
but she just wants kids and like she
really feels like she settles for him
she gets the kids and then half the time
leaves yeah can I be a can I ask a lady
is a question in the room do you want
a traditional man when I say traditional
man I mean the kind because if you're
going depends how far back you want to
go but we're talking like he tells you
it's his rules in his house
right so it's kind of like you utterly
submit to him right yeah he's paying the
bills he's protecting all of those
things but like there are pros of being
traditional yeah but there's the other
side of the coin that you have to accept
as well so I guess I'm asking do you
want do you guys want a traditional
money looking at me so if I'm if I'm
honest if I'm honest I think I could
have been with that when I was younger
so when I when I if my ex-husband if he
treated me like that he would have got
he we would be living like that and it
would have been fine because we got
married young and everything and that's
all I knew but now that um I've had to
grind I've had to go through struggles
and stuff I've had to put myself in
certain situations it will it will take
a lot for me to decide to get into that
I think I'd want a mixture yeah like my
husband I think he is a mixture in terms
of obviously his his word is final but
he lets me do what I want to do there's
no restriction on that on on me so I
still think that's traditional okay I
don't think restriction is necessarily
like if your husband said
um like say say they wanted to go
somewhere and he said no I don't think
you should go would you say
um
I'd ask why mm-hmm
and if it was like if he said babe like
because he's he's in the security world
so he's one as when he says risk I sit
down
and this is what I say sometimes when
because me and omotosi
if I call materials and she's got a man
I say we're going out and she says I'm
not coming I'll be like cool or even if
she and this is why it's when some
people say that um you shouldn't be
friends who with people who are single
because they're bad influence and I
don't believe that because you see my
married friends they can never call me
to tell me we're going to the club I'm
not going to snow club with you what are
you doing there yeah you're an exception
though no but there's a lot of girls
that are like most girls want their
friends to be single so they just wow
this is why I always have anything wrong
with asking your single friend to go
because never take advice from women
because a girl will want to put you in
the same situation she's in how many
girls will get his friends will get a
man and they'll be like oh he's taking
you away from me
I agree with you I agree with you
because I I mean I think girls have fomo
like naturally like if if most girls if
you see all your friends are going to
something you're going to want to go and
if your dude doesn't want you to go like
I've seen
but in any relationship there's going to
be times where you're not yeah but I'm
sorry I keep interrupting sorry sorry no
but I'm saying so like in any
relationship there's going to be times
when you're not and I think sometimes
like when the rubber hits the road like
the single friends aren't the best
influence and I'm not saying all the
time but I'd say by and large you
wouldn't say most women are probably bad
influences on their on their married
friends I would never tell my friend to
leave her husband or do anything that
will impact her marriage if she's doing
something that's wrong I'm gonna tell it
it's regardless I'm single or not
because
I think as you get older and you get
exposed maybe because we're in the
podcast world and you have different
discussions you realize that look
everybody is here for their individual
things like we didn't come into this
world together and we're definitely not
going to leave together so you have to
respect if you love your friend that
much you will Embrace and make sure what
they've got going on is as successful as
possible if you mean that you're the
exception in it
I genuinely think you are an exception I
feel like I think you'll like that
though no no no no yeah when we when I'm
going through my issues and whatever is
to ride it out yeah I know but there's
some like that's like talking to you
one-on-one okay your personal situation
yeah I'm saying like for example as a
single person if my married friend was
having issues in her marriage I'd like
come out with me like let's go do
something like let's go to the club to
get your mind over things but
subconsciously it's it's not a good
influence yeah yeah so but you would be
the same person after after she's had
the fun you'll be the same person to sit
down and tell where she went wrong I've
seen you do it so many I think a big
part of it I I agree I think I think if
a woman feels that the man that she is
with is the top man in the sub she feels
like she won with him right then I think
she's like you know what now I don't
feel like I need to I don't feel like
I'm missing out because I knew how hard
it was to find a man like him but I
think if a girl is or if a woman is with
a man that she feels like she settled
for then she can almost see the
opportunity of going out is still being
able to fish yeah do you have a reason
for going out then going out and also
spines
you can just go out just to enjoy
yourself but I feel women settled why
why do you think women would go to clubs
do women do women settle or do they get
what they can get like to me that's the
same thing yeah but I'm saying like I'm
not getting what I want you're getting
what I can get so it's a set ultimately
right but I want to tell you're settling
if you okay if you go to the store and
you're worth five dollars and you're and
you're bought for five dollars you might
you might have like you know seen seen a
ten dollar product
imagine if you're gonna go to UNI and
you're like oh this is no disrespect
anyone here but it's like oh I'm going
to reading uni like I'm setting him for
ready and I want to go to Oxford it's
like okay well did you get into Oxford
no well then you didn't settle for
Friday that was the best choice for you
because we're all selfish by Design and
this is what happens when the man that's
a 10 bangs a girl that's a three
then you call us deluded because we
think we can get a man that's a 10.
but it's because as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible